the BBC the BBC kind of is if you were
starting from here I don't know whether
you'd necessarily invent it but the fact
is the BBC is a central player in a TV
radio and online environment it's widely
valued by you know many millions of
people the BBC yesterday was able to say
that ninety-seven percent of the UK
population made some use to the BBC in
the course of last year that's up from
ninety-six percent a year before that so
look it's a central player in the game
it's new services are widely respected
both at home and abroad and it is in
that sense the national broadcaster does
that amount along we wouldn't say that
we absolutely have to have it otherwise
the world falls in I'm not sure but it
is what it is and we are where we are
what do you say to those who say that it
over serves white middle-class over 55
year-olds so it looks after the rich and
it doesn't particularly serve very
effectively the poor in the young well
that's that's a fair criticism and I
think in fairness to the BBC they would
they would probably tear that on the
chin to some extent because but they do
their very best I think it's fair to say
to extend their reach beyond that I mean
all television stations nearly all
television station said the all
mainstream TV stations the sky I think I
could include in this will find that
their viewing skews older and so on
that's just that's in though just in the
way of TV I mean the BBC faces the same
challenges as everyone else in the sense
that you know consumer behavior is
changing especially amongst the young
keeping up with that you know is it is a
major job but you know and ever and
everyone is trying i think that the
critical question like the BBC i suppose
as the Charter Review process you know
how it starts it starts off in earnest
is what kind of BBC do you want do you
want to BBC which is sort of broadly
speaking sort of like it is now doing
something for nearly everybody it's big
its central rest of it or do you want to
BBC which is smaller and more restricted
and more confined in its ambition and
doing more of if you like what the
market doesn't that's the way the debate
appears to be shaping up or rather in
families actually that's the way the BBC
is trying to shape the debate pointing
at their opponents and detractors I
think Tony Hall the director-general
said yesterday called them ideologues
and accuse them of being commercially
self or or be
commercially self-interested and said
that they were hugely at odds with the
public who he said want something from
the bebes want a BBC rather which is
roughly speaking sort of like it is now
very different landscape there is no
from its original mission statement to
educate inform and entertain what do you
think it should do well look I mean I'd
say we are where we are and it is what
it is i don't know i think i think my
life personally would be the poorer not
because i do bits of work for them but i
mean as a consumer I think I would be
worse off without it and also if you're
looking for the kind of Center ground
here even in the Conservative Party I
mean the Chancellor when he appeared on
Andrew Marr the other weekends talk
about the raid on the BBC's licence fee
to fund government welfare policy and
over 75 license fees even he said that
although he thought the BBC had imperial
ambitions in the online space was
causing real difficulty for newspapers
by populating parts of the market which
was preventing them from making a living
whether that's true or not a hole tight
but nevertheless that's what he said he
well don't say he thought the BBC was a
central part of British life vitally
important to britts position in the
world and even he thought the BBC should
be should be doing things like strictly
come dancing so II what not even he was
suggesting that it should be radically
reduced in size or scale there are
people who do think that but they I
think it's fair to say they are on the
margins of this argument even the
government seems pretty pretty pretty
committed i would say to a BBC that is
something like it is now is it true i
read earlier on say among developed
countries only germany spends more than
Britain as a share of GDP on it's a
public service broadcaster people who
were watching this afternoon which would
presumably say why should that be
allowed to continue the BBC makes all
these fantastic programs that they sell
around the world including top gear why
should we have to pay for them well the
fact is you do pay for them and that's
how they get made I mean I mean it's a
bit jigar than egg this you wouldn't if
you didn't pay them you wouldn't have
the program's I not said that they have
money out of them so they can use that
funding to make other successful
programming presumably is not it is a
dude what well if that is indeed what
they do and the recent David
Attenborough series gotten on board it's
called 71 percent of the
finance they said that came from
elsewhere so the BBC in it plays quite
effectively you know in the market but
the fact is that it's the licence fee
that pays for them that's why they get
made I'm not saying that you couldn't
imagine a circumstance where the BBC
really wasn't there was a much smaller
player but the question is whether
Britain's creative industry which is now
glow global market leading in some key
genres particularly factual programs and
the like and get it started to get there
in drama it's a huge industry brings in
so because it's 76 billion the earth a
lot of money the BBC sits right at the
core of that and one of the reasons all
those people the celebs have written
that letter to the Telegraph today
supportive EVC is partly because I think
they can see in terms of direct personal
interest that the BBC is critical to so
many of the things that they do even if
they're not in and of themselves BBC
programmes increased technology greater
consumer choice as a result of digital
is it you would accept presumably seva a
flabby organization that no matter how
much the director-general is kicking and
screaming he is going to have to inflict
a major haircut well look the licensee
supplement was the BBC was crying about
last week all be done in secret process
outrageous they said but nevertheless
public excluded completely i should say
they kept saying well you know it's cash
flat yesterday did anna knowledge went
from the BBC's managing director of
operations that it was at least a ten
percent cut now the BBC's had that it's
lighted he's been frozen since 2010 the
BBC was saying privately if not on some
of them saying publicly but if it
continued to be frozen that would mean
major cuts it's now definitely minus ten
and possibly the obr offers a budget
responsibility said minus 20 by the way
it's going to be minus 10 plus something
that's a very serious position for the
BBC to be in so whatever happens you're
absolutely right there is a hair cut
spending absolutely right stipulate
always great to talk to you thanks for
taking the time appreciate it thank you
first Johnson's joining us mp4 up
spreadshirt London Mayor as well of
course sir to talk about water cannon
just while we've got you there what's
your thought on the BBC